All I wanted to do
was fix my email.
I did not expect to have
a minor existential crisis
about how much the world
might be about to change.
Normally this is the sort of talk
that I’d have given on stage
at some conference about
the future of the web,
but, um, I’m in
New Zealand right now,
and I also have this vague suspicion
that those conferences
might not be relevant
for too much longer.
I was lucky enough to live through
the mass adoption of the internet.
For anyone younger than
about 25 watching this,
you won’t remember just how fast
and how incredible
that transformation was.
And I was on the
cutting edge of it,
I was living it,
I was one of the people who
understood what was going on.
Useful new technologies generally
follow a sigmoid curve.
You have a slow takeoff as the
technology is invented
and the major pain points
get sorted out,
and then you have this
incredible explosion of growth
as people find it useful
and the technology gets better
and better and better and better,
and loads of competitors
enter the market,
and people find more and more
and more and more
real-world, practical
uses for it.
And there’s this massive race
to make newer, better, bigger things
that people keep making
more stuff with.
And then you reach the limit of what’s
possible with that technology,
and the rate of progress
flattens out again.
Basically, there’s a reason
very few people
camp outside Apple Stores
for the new iPhone any more.
I remember Napster from back in 1999.
And in hindsight, I think Napster
was the first big sign
of just how many industries
were going to be changed
or completely destroyed
by the internet.
Not just the music industry,
but travel agents, video rental stores,
encyclopaedias, shopping malls,
big-box stores, the postal service,
journalism, the entire media industry.
Napster wasn’t the first sign,
but it was the first major one
that millions of non-technical
people were using by choice.
The first one to get big mass-media
attention and legal problems.
It was the first big
popular disruption,
the first warning shot,
the first rumble of thunder
off in the distance that said
the storm was approaching,
that everything was about to change.
I don’t think many people realised
that at the time.
And even if they did,
they couldn’t have predicted
the world that would follow.
The world I grew up in,
the world that I’ve got
really comfortable with,
the world of the web, of
social media, of smartphones.
This video you’re watching now
is a very early-2023 video,
and a very English-speaking one.
This is a record of a point
in time and space.
And I might be wrong about this,
I don’t know where technology’s
going to go from here.
But: I think that world,
my world, the one I grew up in,
is about to change radically.
I think we’re on a new sigmoid curve,
and I have no idea how far along
that curve we are right now.
And I don’t know if I want
to change with it…
but I think I’ll have to.
And all I was trying to do
was fix my email.
This is a really specific problem,
but it really annoyed me,
and I have to explain it for
the rest of this to make sense,
so bear with me.
Almost every email system
has the idea of folders.
You have one copy of an email,
and once you’re done with it,
you file it in a folder
like a piece of paper
in a filing cabinet,
because that’s the mid-20th-century
physical analogy
that the inventors went with.
But. In 2004,
Google launched Gmail,
which threw all that out
in favour of labels.
Email is just in one big pile,
you search to find stuff,
and you add labels
to help you sort it.
I hate labels, because
I like the analogy of folders,
that’s what I started out with,
that’s what I was already using.
I didn’t want to change for no reason.
But everything else about Gmail
was so much better
than any of the alternatives
at the time
that I moved over to it
a couple of years later.
And I decided, fine, I will
just treat labels like folders,
I’ll change my workflow
as little as possible.
Each thread gets one label.
That’s like putting
it into a folder?
Which meant that when I backed up
my emails, which I do,
never trust having only
one copy of something,
particularly if that copy’s
up in the cloud,
but when I did that,
I could use
a regular old-school
desktop email program
like Microsoft Outlook
to make that backup.
You can use programs
like that with Gmail accounts,
they talk to each other.
If they didn’t, stuff like the
default Mail app on iPhones
wouldn’t work,
and people would complain.
But those old-school systems
don’t understand labels,
so Gmail just lies and
says they’re folders.
Great! That means my
email program
can talk to Gmail, and request
a copy of all those messages,
one “folder” at a time,
and then I know it’s
backed up every message.
They’re even stored in
actual email folders, like I wanted!
It took fifteen years
for me to notice:
that wasn’t working properly.
I was doing a routine backup last month,
and I noticed that a thread
in that email backup
was missing several
recent messages.
And that made me suspicious,
the kind of discomfort that you get
when you know something is wrong,
but you don’t know what it is yet.
So I looked a little bit further,
and I realised loads of messages
were missing in my backup.
More than a hundred thousand
of them, over fifteen years.
They were still there in Gmail,
on the web. They hadn’t been lost.
It’s just they hadn’t been backed up.
And that’s because, it turns out,
in Gmail, labels only attach to
individual messages
and not the full thread.
That is invisible to most people.
It’s barely mentioned
in the documentation.
And it’s a really subtle,
annoying distinction.
If you send an email,
put a label on that thread,
get a reply, and then
just hit “Archive”:
that reply doesn’t get the label.
And as you go back and forth,
and add to that thread,
none of the other messages there
get a label
unless you explicitly
untag and retag the whole thread.
Which means more than 100,000
unlabelled messages
weren’t in my backup.
Is this a really specific, nerdy problem
that only I’m annoyed about?
Yes. Absolutely. I’m one of the very
few people in the world
that it’s going to affect.
Loads of people don’t sort or label
their emails at all,
and most don’t back them up.
But I needed to fix this,
I needed my backup to work,
and I did not want to
change my damn workflow.
But how on earth do I fix
every email thread over fifteen years,
without painstakingly clicking
through all of them?
I grew up fixing things with code,
so obviously,
that’s where my brain went.
Google has a service
called Apps Script.
It means that anyone
can write simple code
to easily change and
automate things
in Gmail, Calendar, Docs, YouTube,
whatever.
It’s a brilliant service,
I’ve no idea how it ever got made!
And it will inevitably, one day,
be shut down with very little warning,
because that’s just what Google does.
But Apps Script meant
that to fix this problem,
I could just spend an hour or so
writing a bit of code.
And it’s been a while
since I’ve done that!
First thing I do when I’m coding
something that’s simple like that,
is I write out what it’s meant to do
in plain English.
Just the flow of logic,
so I can then use that as a guide.
So I wrote it,
and then I thought,
hang on, isn’t there an AI thing
that’s meant to do this now?
Yes, this is a video
partly about ChatGPT,
but I promise I’m not going
to go into the details there.
Telling someone about your
fascinating AI conversation
is like telling someone
about your dreams.
They don’t care, it just sounds
like you’re hallucinating nonsense.
But I’d seen posts from people
being freaked out about
how good ChatGPT is and,
intellectually, yeah,
I looked at it
and I agreed with them.
It seemed surprisingly good.
But it is just a text transformer.
All it does is guess what the
next word in the phrase is.
I knew that we’d been seeing
some improvements in that lately.
I made a video two years ago about
“the sentences computers can’t
understand, but humans can”,
and at the end of that video,
I made a joke about how computers
with language skills are ten years away,
just as they have been
for the last 40 years.
I was wrong.
Turns out that’s pretty much solved now.
But ChatGPT is still just a thing
that predicts
what the next word is going to be.
It produces generic, milquetoast output
that’s confidently wrong
about a lot of things.
It’s going to help spammers
and maybe have
a little bit of real-world use.
Right?
But I thought, okay,
let’s put my text description in,
tell it to translate to this
obscure Google Apps Script,
see what it does.
…and it wrote the code for me.
In a few seconds.
And I felt this pit-of-the-stomach,
existential horror,
and at that moment,
I couldn’t explain why:
but I figured it out later.
It’s just predicting
the next word.
The code it gave back was
a bit wrong, but frankly,
my first attempt would’ve
been a bit wrong.
So I asked it in plain English
to fix a couple of the
errors that I’d spotted,
and it did, and that version
was nearly right.
Not quite, though.
It used a really strange approach.
I tried to work out
why it had done that,
and then I realised,
I could just ask.
And it told me, in English,
why it had done that.
And it had made the same mistake
I did with my backup.
Because, turns out,
Google’s documentation is wrong,
Google Apps Script itself treats labels
as attaching to threads not messages.
Google wrote their own
programming language wrong!
So I told ChatGPT about the error.
And it fixed the script.
It bodged its way around Google’s
bad documentation
to build the thing I was
actually asking for.
And after all the
back-and-forths,
I didn’t actually
save much time!
But it was so much easier.
I never had to
pore through documentation
to find the exact specific
magical incantation that I needed.
Also, my coding skills are
years out of date.
That’s one of the reasons I don’t
make computer science videos any more.
The last time I learned a new thing
in code was probably 2015.
My old skills were good enough.
I didn’t want to change my workflow.
I’m not sure if ChatGPT is a
better coder than I am,
but it felt about equal.
It felt like watching
while someone wrote code,
with me occasionally
chiming in and going,
‘um, I think you might have
made a mistake there?’
And sometimes, I was the one
who made the mistake.
At one point, I realised
I’d written the wrong thing in
that first text description,
ChatGPT had just been following
my wrong instructions.
I know it’s just a text model that
predicts what word comes next,
but it didn’t feel like it.
So at first, I thought
that pit-of-the-stomach
existential-dread feeling
was because my brain
had gone ‘that’s a human’,
or ‘that’s an alien intelligence’.
Or because I was
starting to think, well,
what if my brain is just
a transformer system
that’s trying to predict
what the next word is?
I’m sure I remember some
old pop-science article
about how your brain’s
a prediction engine
and “surprise” is just a fancy word
for “being wrong about what comes next”.
But then the next day I gave
ChatGPT a more difficult problem,
one that required not just
translating English to code,
but actually a bit of
a logical leap,
and it just confidently, completely
failed in multiple, obvious ways.
And that meant that I wasn’t worried
about it coming for my job.
Not yet, anyway.
Sure, no-one’s asked for that
exact problem to be solved before,
the one about the labels and messages.
ChatGPT wasn’t just copying
and pasting from somewhere,
there was arguably creativity involved.
But, if I’m honest, a lot of the
programming I used to do
was just copying and pasting
bits from somewhere.
At some point, every modern programmer
searched on Google or Stack Overflow
and “adapted” something
that someone else wrote.
It’s basically part of
the job at this point.
I’m deliberately avoiding
the argument about
creativity, AI art, and copyright,
by the way.
I don’t know how
I feel about it,
and I don’t know how
the courts will resolve it.
If I hired a human
artist or musician
to create a painting or song
in a more famous artist’s style,
that would be weird…
but it would be legal.
As long as they’re not pretending
to be the famous artist,
as long as the smaller artist is not
trading on their name, that’s fine.
The style of most of my videos
on this channel
is just a slightly faster version of
the TV shows I watched growing up.
That’s what this intelligence was trained on.
And this video is basically in the style
of every other video essayist on YouTube.
It’s just I tend to go to the beach
a bit more often. [seagull screaming]
If someone set up an AI to
generate YouTube videos,
or even YouTube educational videos
as a genre,
I think I’d be fine with that?
I don’t think I’d have a problem
with my work being a small part
of a massive pool
of training data.
But if someone started ripping off
specifically my name and my work?
Yeah, I can see why artists
are furious about that.
The British legal term for it
is “passing off”.
I’ve said before:
please don’t train models
on what I make.
Or, frankly, on anyone specific
without their consent?
But okay, I wasn’t worried
about being replaced,
and I wasn’t worried that
I was actually talking
to some human-equivalent
alien artificial intelligence.
So why did I still have
that feeling of dread?
Artificial intelligence,
text transformers and diffusion models,
everything that we’re
currently seeing,
seems to be on that
sigmoid curve of progress.
And I don’t know what point
on that curve we’ve got to.
If we’re already most of the
way up that curve, then cool.
Programmers and artists
have brand new tools,
but they can’t create something
at a human level with them.
It’s not going to
take many jobs.
It’s gonna make people’s
work more efficient,
the same way that loads
of inventions,
like Photoshop,
have done before.
If we’re at the middle of
that curve, then wow,
we’re gonna get some really
impressive new tools very soon,
that still need some
humans to work them.
Maybe Siri and the Google Assistant
are going to become the things
hey were always promised to be.
But that feeling of dread came
from the idea that ChatGPT,
and the new AI art systems,
might be to my world what Napster
was to the late nineties.
The herald, the first big warning
that this new technology, the thing that
was going to change everything,
was starting to actually
change everything.
Where huge numbers of people,
not just the nerds,
were actively using it.
And it didn’t matter that Napster
got sued out of existence,
because by then there was Morpheus
and Grokster and LimeWire and KaZaA.
And then there was Spotify.
The old business model, that idea
that you bought a copy of music,
had been struck a mortal blow
and no-one noticed it for a while.
If you hear echoes of the Napster case
in the lawsuits against AI art programs…
so do I.
I was getting a haircut
the other week,
and unprompted, the barber started
talking about ChatGPT,
and how he’d actually used it
to write a formal email
that he couldn’t be bothered
to put together himself.
He wasn’t a particularly
technical person,
he wasn’t a nerd like me,
but he’d used it easily,
the same way that someone who wanted
to get a load of music for free
would figure out Napster.
It’s not about ChatGPT,
not specifically.
It’s about what it represents.
Because if we’re still at the
start of the curve for AI,
if we’re at the Napster point,
then everything is about to change,
just as fast and just as strangely
as it did in the early 2000s,
perhaps beyond all recognition…
and this time I’m
on the wrong end of it.
I’m like the music executive,
back in ’99.
It feels, to me, like something
might have just gone very wrong
for the now-comfortable world
that I grew up with
and that I’ve settled down in.
That’s where the dread came from.
The worry that suddenly
I don’t know what comes next.
No-one does.
I’ve been complaining for years
that it feels like
nothing has really changed
since smartphones came along…
and I think that maybe,
maybe,
I should have been careful
what I wished for.
At some point, I’ll look back
on this video and, with hindsight,
I will easily be able to see
where we were on the curve.
We all will.
Part of me hopes that
I am entirely wrong,
that in a few years I’ll
still be working like this.
The email thing is
a metaphor, of course,
it won’t be email
folders for you.
It might be something else,
something you’re attached to.
Maybe something minor,
or maybe the whole
industry you work in.
But right now, that feeling,
that creeping horror, that dread:
it turns out that was the worry
that after years of being
fairly steady and comfortable,
my world is about to change…
and despite everything,
I will still want my email
to be in folders.
…and now, an AI-generated NordVPN ad!
Today I want to talk about one
of my favorite tools
for staying connected
while travelling
or just browsing the internet.
It’s called NordVPN and it’s
been a game-changer for me.
With NordVPN, I can access content
from anywhere in the world,
no matter where I am.
Whether I’m in a country with
strict internet censorship,
or I want to access a web site
that blocks people
from a particular country,
or just want to catch up on
my favorite shows from back home,
NordVPN has got me covered.
Some other amazing
features of NordVPN
include the ability to connect
up to six devices simultaneously,
and 24/7 customer support.
Whether I’m using my
laptop, tablet, or phone,
NordVPN makes it easy to
stay connected and secure.
So, if you’re looking for a VPN
that can help you access content
from around the world and
keep you safe and secure online,
give NordVPN a try.
Trust me, you won’t regret it!
To get the best deal
they’re currently offering,
go to nordvpn.com/tomscott or
click the link in the description.
I am going to be out of a job soon.